have you know been in
backseat of an f15 on a combat mission
I've been in the streets of Baghdad I've
been a moderator at presidential debates
there is nothing that has been our
meaningful in my career leanness when I
first met all these soldiers and then
later their spouses and sat them down
for interviews and I'd heard the story I
was not in the bathroom and the
reporters were also caught up in
covering the policy or covering where
were they at WMDs where was this that
we'd forgotten there was a war going on
we were so busy covering the effects of
going into war when I heard those
stories about this battle I said we have
to do it Americans have become used to
hearing about casualties
they've become used to mass casualties
with our military but this was one of
the first times this had happened to us
as Americans if you you have to think
back what that was like these soldiers
had no clue they were going to end up in
combat no clue at all their fathers
husbands their wives that that emotional
goodbye they thought they were going to
keep the peace over there they really
know what it would happen that would
have been a much much more difficult
scene
I think I was also surprised because
even though all the actors talk about
finding the essence of the character
they don't want to be exactly what the
real people were like I was surprised
how close they came to those characters
and and the soldiers and the wives that
I know they really did capture who those
people are you cannot look at them
recreate those scenes and recreate those
characters and not think of the real
soldiers and the real families and and
what they went through
[Music]
you